what's the biggest mistake a filmmaker
can make before day 1 on a movie set
before day one day one of shooting
uh-huh
Wow okay I mean let me think on that
first the biggest mistake I like I'm not
showing up well this poor performer but
you'd not you narrowed it down to before
day way in other words before they go
into production something maybe they
overlooked something they sort of
micromanage that shouldn't have been
micromanage I don't know and I don't
know and in terms of overlooking
something a micromanaging I were down to
details and it could be there could be a
lot of things but I think one of the
biggest mistakes a director can make and
one that I've made frequently way too
often is assuming that I know what I
want
assuming I'm talking about for the whole
movie and every scene every moment
really convinced I know exactly what I
want and know I do know what I want but
what I'm talking about is the assumption
that that is that is what eventually I
will want in the film in other words
closing my mind of something beyond that
other than that I think the biggest
thing a director has to do is keep their
mind open to the two possibilities
beyond what they've imagined even no
matter how much they've rehearsed it no
matter how much they've worked on the
script no matter all the preparation
that they're doing as they going into
production keep your mind open one thing
that's very important in the whole
filmmaking process and I'm going to talk
about now just working with actors for a
second I'm going to go way back and
actors who come in and for an audition
okay our actors looking for a job
wanting a job meeting job whatever
actors once they're cast your actors in
our cast another cast and but you
haven't hit production yet are now a
different breed of animal
totally they are actors who have a job
and so they and you'll notice that it's
really interesting after you cast the
movie and then you're bringing the
actors together maybe for the first
reading they are totally different then
not this the same sort of needy
compliant careful people they're little
arrogant they're a little full of
themselves over their little 54 everyone
has changed in a slightly different way
they're not quite the same people and it
can be sort of horrifying like did I get
the right people here because they're
different now okay so now you're in the
rehearsal process and all that nib and
you're going through that and you're
aiming going you're in pre-production
and you're going towards production okay
and you're rehearsing whatever you're
doing which we can talk about later then
you hit production they change again and
now it's the person who walks on the set
and they know today is the day we're
shooting that scene they are under
enormous pressure so there are three
different stages so as you go into
production getting back to your question
be aware that these people that have a
shift in they're different now they may
be more problematic than maybe more
compliant they may be more irritating
they may be more charming who knows what
they're going to be but they're human
and they're under enormous pressure now
so they will try to shift to their
places of comfort and all that so but
again getting back to your question
about the mistakes you can make keep
your mind open these people these actors
under enormous pressure now who you've
worked with however much you've worked
with them who knows what they're going
to come up with who knows how that scene
that you just rehearsed three weeks ago
that you thought was so wonderful in the
rehearsal room and now you're going to
shoot it it's going to shift it's going
to change because the actors have
changed keep your mind open ideally this
goes back to the rehearsal process and
all that which we haven't talked about
but ideally if you've been rehearsing
deeply enough
finally enough ideally those actors are
going to go even deeper on you because
that's pressure they will go deeper into
the character and they will start
revealing stuff to you that you had
probably never imagined don't try to
make the movie in production that you
had thought you were making in
pre-production it's going to shift it's
going to change ideally if the process
that you've been going through a bit
working on the film has been to go for
the depth of characters it's going to
get deeper it's going to get better but
you have to be flexible
and then actually can show up and
suddenly they're doing that scene in a
way you never imagined now you have a
problem not because they're doing it
different what do you do do you try to
get them back to what you had before or
you to let them go their way they're
going okay this is in other words don't
assume that you have to try to keep it
to what you are thinking before there's
a chapter or section of my book
production that I call the nightly
reconsideration process which is very
simply this you read the script you
imagine a movie you cast it in all that
now you're in pre-production and you're
working on rehearsal and putting
together all the elements and the movie
and your imagination is getting more
detailed but it's shifting it's shifting
from what it was when you first read it
now it's coming into some kind of
perceived reality although it's not
really there yet now you're in
production and as you start production
the entire movie is in your head to some
degree you can see it you can feel it
you know what you're going for you shoot
the first scene I can guarantee you that
scene will not turn out the way you
thought it was going to in fact I can go
into you for everything you did to it
won't turn out exactly the way you
thought but the nightly reconsideration
process is on that first day so you
shoot two scenes one scene to scene
suddenly you have shot some material
that is going to be in your movie that
scene has now
been defined by what you shot the
possibilities the range of it
it's been limited actually down to what
you shot it hasn't been expanded it's
been limited and now because that exists
use it's automatically you start
reconsidering the entire movie well that
seems plain that way then oh then it's
going to stop it's it's a living growing
thing and so every night you are
reconsidering the entire movie
well she with white she was tougher in
that than I thought she was going to be
well if that's the way oh my god is it
going to go that way how do I want it to
go now so you've got to keep your eyes
open because the characters are now the
characters are now determining where
your movie is going not you sounds like
then plan but be open plan but be open
ok yes have yes have a good plan have a
strong but have a definite plan that
what you are convinced will work and
then be flexible be willing to throw it
out I'll be willing to adapt it adjust
it
you